ça veut dire que vous continuez à voter
pendant l'émission puisque c'était un
petit peu plus
au début de l'émission et vous continuez
à le faire parce qu'on vous pose une
autre question celle ci elle porte sur
un des points particuliers qui a été
abordé par emmanuel macron quand il a eu
justement cette phrase
la seule réponse est de bâtir un modèle
économique durable plus fort de travail
et de produire davantage pour ne pas
dépendre des autres
alors cette petite phrase n'est pas
tombée dans l'oreille d'un sourd en tout
cas elle a été remarquée par nos
confrères de france info qui ce matin
ont demandé la traduction au ministre de
l'économie et des finances bruno le
maire veut dire travailler tous
c'est ça le défi qui est pas la même
chose travailler davantage ainsi ça veut
dire qu'il faut que le plus grand nombre
de français puissent trouver un travail
dans une période où je les dis nous
anticipons 800 mille suppressions
d'emplois en france
c'est ça notre objectif partagé que tous
les français puissent trouver un travail
bon alors en écoutant le ministre de
l'économie ce matin et pardonnez-moi de
cette confidence en comptant le nombre
de jours de vacances qui me restent à
prendre
je me retrouve totalement dans la
question qu'on vous pose sur twitter et
qui a été posée également par jean
baptiste émergents
peut-on travailler davantage sans
renoncer aux 35 heures sylvie bommel
vous êtes de nous tous celle qui a été
la plus confrontés au problème
est-ce que vous avez une réponse à cette
question
oui je pense qu'on peut travailler
davantage en chantier dans son sens
venir chez 35 avant 35 heures n'ont pas
fêté lors ont fait leurs 20 ans et on en
est encore pour voir si les anglais ou
pas ce qui est vraiment un incroyable
parce que les 35 heures ce matin dans la
vraie vie
dans la réalité on travaille bien plus
que 35 heures toutes les études de bon
sens l'a simplement c'est un seul le
soleil qui déclenche les heures
supplémentaires mais les français
travaillent plus que 35 heures c'est un
seuil alors après plus que tout ça parce
que l'arrêté
c'est un symbole c'est un symbole et la
question c'est un peu ce qu'il faut
déboulonner les 35 heures près ce qu'il
faut faire tomber la statue et 35 ans je
crois que oui il faudrait qu on peut pas
on peut pas parce que c'est un symbole
incroyable et le symbole d'une année où
on a promis aux français qu'en
travaillant moins
oui on aurait moins de chômage plus que
ça à 2
c'est dommage taille sa coupe et donc le
temps doux retrouve voilà donc je vous
laisse reprendre votre votre
démonstration sylvie jeu judith et que
le problème 35 heures c'est que oui
faudrait en finir avec les 35 heures
mais qu'on peut pas en finir parce qu'en
réalité elle joue plus appliquée depuis
longtemps la zad détricoter la droite la
gauche on sait bien que ont été les
français trahit bien plus que 35 heures
les toutes les études le disent et ce
qu'ils restent tels symboles ce symbole
qu'on a expliqué 2000 aux français que
en travaillant moins
il pourrait partager le travail y aurait
moins de chômeurs et je disais on a vu
ce que ça a donné
et bien que ça que en travaillant moins
on serait plus heureux donc c'est l'idée
que le travail c'est moche et que ses
entrailles de moi c'est mieux ainsi un
gâteau qui est pas bon donc si on monte
on joue ce sera mieux
ben moi je dis qu'il faut que le gâteau
soit plus sucré et et tous rapports au
travail c'est peut-être ça aussi qu'il a
voulu dire alors il ya beaucoup de
français qui sont qui sont partants là
dedans c'est évident un on l'a vu
beaucoup dans les magasins vous l'avez
vu il y avait des tas de gens que de
très content de travailler il compte
tenu des conditions difficiles que les
sourires desquels si elle sera axée
toujours pas s'il y met et puis il ya
une partie pour lequel de travail c'est
moche et là ça va être compliqué je
pense que c'est ça aussi qui veut des
retrouves tourner ou les manches
il a dit à un moment il faut travailler
tellement que le retour au travail cela
on sait bien que des problèmes avec le
retour au travail
je pense qu'une partie des gens qui ont
peur encore c'est ce que les lexiques
appelle le syndrome de la cabane mais
mais mais mais il ya aussi une partie
qui le bond est peut-être il faut
regarder du côté des offres en peu de
mal à revenir au boulot rien peut alors
qu'ils avaient commencé dans l'ordre
j'ai demandé l'avis des libéraux d'abord
christophe christophe de voogd on n'a
pas honte sich qui nous dit les 35
heures c'est du vent en france on peut
bosser jusqu'à 48 heures en tout média
ou alors ils la jugent très calme
entièrement d'accord avec ce qu'a dit
cette analyse je voudrais quand même
terrible distinction majeure surtout
après ce qu'on a pu être
entre secteur privé et secteur public à
dire que les 35 heures dans le secteur
public où j'ai la chance d'être croyez
moi c'est une réalité et ce même
peut-être même pas une réalité comme
disait un homme de gauche
j'aimerais bien que le secteur public 5
heures et ça n'oublions pas que ça des
conséquences
ça a évidemment des conséquences
fiscales et de dépenses
j'en profite d'ailleurs sur ce point je
reviens un peu là dessus pourquoi ne
dire ne pas reconnaître nous sommes
champions du monde de la dépense
publique et les prélèvements puisque
c'est le cas et pourquoi dire nous
sommes l'un des pays non seul le
champion d'une parenthèse donc
distinguant le privé le public je crois
que ce qu'a dit bruno le maire et à ses
sens et le problème de la france c'est
pas la productivité horaire vous savez
que travailleur français sont très
productifs en tout cas encore une fois
dans le privé c'est le problème de la
quantité c'est la productivité du pays
c'est à dire le nombre d'heures
travaillées par rapport à la population
en âge et notre problème française c'est
le fait que beaucoup de chômeurs
nous rentrons tard sur le marché du
travail nous en saurons tôt et se taxer
caractéristiques s'accentue avec la
crise et c'est là que je comprends vois
ce que je jette après ce qu'a dit le
président
elle que l'apôtre une ola d'huile comme
en effet l'idée d'une productivité
globale non pas une volonté de retour
sur les 35 heures qui est devenu en
effet un peu à mon avis une querelle
théologique qui peut quand même avoir
son sens encore une fois dans la
fonction publique
nicolas lecaussin ccsa c'est une
querelle théologique on peut reprendre
ce que d'ici champ des 30 on peut bosser
aujourd'hui jusqu'à 48 heures en toute
légalité
on peut bosser plus si oui si on fait
les heures supplémentaires mais moi et
je crains c'est qu'on sait qu'on trouve
un port est accordée hainard qui vont
trouver une autre solution un bon
trouver une autre excuse
notre usine évoquerez notre usine à gaz
pour ne pas supprimer les 35 heures
c'est ce qu'il faut faire c'est super
mais un simple est alors mis ce pays à
être enceinte ça n'existait pas et
surtout maintenant l'exemple l'exemple
de l'hôpital français quand même
symptomatique les 35 heures plus tôt les
32 heures vous venez de le dire mais
c'était un problème pour la france est
une des cause la catastrophe a lancé
avec la belle opération et ça sonne je
ne suis pas la seule à dire cela au
dégoût d'un ces rapports c'est la
fédération président à faire de la
science à la nuit et il ya un problème
il a un problème d'absentéisme mais un
problème de compte et partant qui est
l'un des 35 heures et tout cela il faut
mettre à pas il faudrait supprimer les
35 heures
et justement donné la liberté de travail
puisse continuer un an ce qui est le cas
dans votre pays
un suisse en suède et donc les critiques
qui sont pourtant un des pays où les
danses existe donc ne créons pas autre
chose une autre usine à gaz supprimant
les 35 heures si le monde georges que
soit donné de chevaux de point de vue
alors sachant que vous êtes de gauche
mais vous connaissez bien le privé aussi
donc c'est ça qui m'intéresse dans votre
votre réponse d'abord je peux pas
laisser dire que l'hôpital souffre des
35 heures alors que nous venons d'avoir
un corps soignant dans son ensemble des
aides-soignants aux médecins qui ont
obtenu le pays et qui ont travaillé 60
70 heures certains 80 heures n'ont pas
vu leurs familles pendant des semaines
et alors que ils se sont plaints pendant
des années que des énarques justement
très néo libéraux s'amuse à détruire
l'hôpital français et à leur mettre un
nombre incroyable de managers qui
n'avait qu'une fonction c'était réduire
les coûts réduire les coûts réduire les
coûts pendant un an avant cette crise je
rappelle que les médecins et les
soignants ont fait des grèves pour
expliquer qu'il n'y a pas de moyens on
les a pas écoutés
je crois que ceux qui ne l'ont pas
écouté un particulier ce gouvernement en
quelques milliers de morts sur la
conscience parce qu'on aurait plus de
respirateurs et plus de lits ceci étant
dit sur les 35 heures on a affaire un
serpent de mer de la politique française
il faut quand même rappeler quelque
chose c'est que on parle
de la loi des 35 heures mais en fait
c'est la loi aubry 2 et la loi aubry 2
n'a jamais été abrogée par la droite ni
par tous ceux qui critiquaient les 35
heures parce que la loi aubry 2 c'est un
peu les 35 heures mais c'est surtout
l'annualisation du temps de travail et
l'organisation de ces aux 35 heures
branche par branche entreprise par
entreprise
c'est à dire deux mesures que la droite
n'aurait jamais dû passer s'ils étaient
au pouvoir et qui inverse la hiérarchie
des normes et fragilise les salariés
puisque ça casse le cadre national de la
loi le cadre national de la loi du
travail et de toute façon comme la du
site on peut travailler quarante huit
heures il suffit que celui qui vous
embauche acceptent de payer un peu plus
ou alors lors en bourse ou d'une autre
manière comment on fait dans les
entreprises dans laquelle je suis en en
rtt
une autre remarque et c'est bien de
vouloir faire travailler plus les gens
mais encore une fois ça se confronte aux
le haut mur la raison comment voulez
vous faire travailler plus de gens avec
10% de chômeurs auxquels vont s'ajouter
un million de chômeurs c'est à dire quoi
hier que le travail qui n'existe pas on
le prend encore plus il y en a encore
moins pour ceux qui sont dehors
en particulier les jeunes et puis une
dernière chose parce qu'il apparaît
d'indépendance et il y avait une
question de vos nouveaux auditeurs sur
la haye ce que est ce qu'il est pour
plus de protectionnisme mais non alors
que monsieur m'a comparé la dépendance
nous venons de signer un nouveau un
nouvel accord de libre échange avec le
vietnam
le problème de ce pays c'est qu'il est d
industrialiser et que tout le monde ne
peut pas être dans le secteur tertiaire
ou fonctionnaires il n'y a pas à cette
fin il faut une réindustrialisation
or malheureusement avec ses traités de
libre-échange cette impossibilité
justement à cause des traités européens
de faire du protectionnisme
je vois très mal comment on va s'en
sortir en rajoutant le fait que l'a
récemment psa dans le nord à embaucher
500 espagnols et polonais alors qu'il ya
500 français intérimaires qui sont
restés sur le carreau
ceci grâce à la dérogation à la
disposition sur les travailleurs
détachés
donc on est très très mal barré bien
société paul c'est définitive
votre
réactions et peut-être pour aller un
petit peu plus loin justement répondre à
cette question mais comment
pour répondre à la question et aux défis
lancés par le président comment
travailler davantage aujourd'hui sylvie
et bien je crois qu'il a fait appel il
ya quand même à laon on raisonne à taux
constants il a il a quand même là quand
même parler non pas de l'industrie
annoncés il ya des choses qui sont
impliqués mais quand même rapatrié des
choses comme ça c'est une évidence
et puis on peut aussi créer quand même
créer des entreprises
vous m'entendez oui on peut créer le
secteur associatif dont on parle peu et
un secteur c'est qu'il ya montré lui
aussi pendant pendant cette crise qui
est un grand pourvoyeur d'emplois en
france a montré toute son énergie et sa
capacité à aider
enfin assumé services pour la population
donc je crois que c'est ça s'il faut
créer alors qu'il ait de la valeur par
tous bien sûr bien sûr j'y crois
possible
nicolas sur cette idée donc soulevé par
allociné qu'on a vu de la montée des
jeunes dans la vie quotidienne
on a vu laventie vite et quand même de
nos restaurants et a passé une période
de 6 des pensions comment je vois des
comment il s'est créé tous ces petits
ces trucs emporté bon alors les le
télétravail l'application des limites et
n'importe quoi à domicile je crois qu'il
ya des réserves de l'inventivité et il a
dit ça il a parlé de d'inventivité je
crois qu'on peut on peut trouver des
solutions travailler plus avec des
nouveaux créneaux
nicolas votre votre point de vue sur ça
et sur effectivement à la fois le
secteur associatif et l'ingéniosité des
français ben justement c'est le moment
donc de leur donner la possibilité de
s'exprimer de leur donner de l'air et
les français peuvent très bien créer des
entreprises
regardez ce qui s'est passé au début
du confinement au début de la crise et
avait pénurie de masques et de jeunes et
puis des pénuries de produits
alimentaires dans les supermarchés mais
les pénuries alimentaires de petits
génies salué le caractère donc le
secteur privé tout de suite et s'est
réorganisée amazon a livré qu'il faut
les libérer soir domicile sont bien
passées la concurrence a marché le
secteur le savez très bien sont ils
il faut il faut par exemple c'est l'état
qui a failli dans cette histoire c'est
l'hôpital français qui a failli alors il
a au budget et c'est le premier budget
en europe la santé c'est la france et le
dialogue
c'est l'hôpital français qui reçoit le
plus d'argent des doutes et de la santé
cds sont les chiffres d'eurostat son
équipe de l'état français c'est vrai ça
donc je veux pas dire qu'il ya pas
d'argent donc il faut justement
instaurer la concurrence instaurée la
responsabilité alors de les français
responsable ils sont créateurs
d'entreprise
il faut les inciter il faut leur donner
la possibilité de créer des emplois on
ne partage pas le travail on le
craignait
on crée des emplois si ça ce qu'il faut
comme le font les autres pays qui ont
beaucoup plus d'emplois que nous aidons
hilton chômage beaucoup plus se battre
la france mais le passage si je devais
en retenir qu'un sur les pesanteurs
administratives ce qu'il a dit si jamais
il y arrive mais ça ça va être compliqué
l état au front et à les réglementations
steira moi je suis sioniste race née
d'une association jamais on a été aussi
libre que pendant cette période jamais
on a pu mettre sylvette en place des
choses mais demain c'est son projet le
travail dépend de la gazette ça va être
l'enfer à nouveau déjà la ds a demandé
pour chaque bénéficiaire
ensuite nous fassions un rapport du
confinement
c'est juste un détail si tu ne dis
également arrêté de parler d'emploi il
faut parler production mais c'est ce que
je disais je suis je remercie vincent
d'avoir cité ce papier sur dans marianne
sur ces bourgeois de gauche qui se cache
derrière intersectionnelle pour éviter
de parler de lutte des classes
mais là on est confronté des bourgeois
de droite qui oublient que nous sommes
dans un pays de 70 millions d'habitants
et tout le monde ne peut pas être encore
une fois tertiaire restaurateurs ou
créer son entreprise
ce pays en 30 ans a perdu la moitié de
son emploi industriel et justement on a
un problème grave de production et si
nous n'avions pas autant de chômeurs
parce qu'on à délocaliser massivement on
aurait sûrement moins de dépenses
publiques et les gens pourraient
travailler ils auraient de meilleurs
collecte d'impôts sur les salaires de
ceux qui travaillent et ils pourraient
dépenser on pourrait relancer l'économie
et donc et puis je comprends pas très
bien cette histoire d'état profond et
six 6 mois ici même mes amis et tous
ceux que vous connaissez ne ment pas
qu'ils passent l'ena et qui vont à
sciences po
c'est plutôt des écoles du néo
libéralisme le plus strict et si un état
profond et c'est un état profond ultra
néolibérale je vous cite par exemple un
énarque célèbre qui vient d'être nommé à
la cour des comptes a certes un monsieur
moscovici soi-disant du pays socialistes
et qui est très
est ce que voit que ça christophe mais
il faut aller un petit bon alors je veux
juste quelques précisions parce que si
on vraiment senti les faits on peut en
raison l'hôpital français et deux côté
europe donc été un petit peu les
histoires de stérilité c'est le plus
doté et aura en moyenne
et la deuxième chose c'est que je crois
que je vais aller dans le sens de sidi
bommel la question quand même des normes
règlements sur l'inspiration vous allez
récemment
pourquoi est ce que les gens sont dont
georges pourquoi est ce que les gens
quittent la france est ce que vous voyez
la femme créée en france monsieur bon
bon des gens j'aime tes fesses mais
pourquoi est ce que les gens quittent la
france peut-être les entrepreneurs
pourquoi est ce que les entreprises
délocalisent peut-être que la charge
fiscale des quelque chose peut-être que
notre sueur animations et des
régulations libre échangiste non hélas
je vous rappelle il estime aaron si vous
y allez faire sans deux points de pib de
surpoids ministre hâtif de la thur
administration et enfin pour connaître
un petit peu ce milieu là renseignements
m à sciences po
mais vos énarque comment vous avez 10
mégas
néo libéraux mais a failli coûter
présenté moi moi j'en ai jamais
rencontré mais c'est essayer de passer
justement essayer de passer un examen de
l'ena sur les questions économiques en
défendant ligne keynésienne une batterie
jamais mais tout ce que je connais sont
obligés d'apprendre la doxa néolibérale
afin de réussir à rentrer dans le saint
des saints de l'ena les agences
régionales de santé ces deux modèles du
néolibéralisme quoique les monos tout à
fait de sens
non c'est fait pour tout ça est fait
pour fracasser l'hôpital français le
plus maîtrisé à terme mais s'il n'y a
pas assez de moyens si vous trouvez
qu'il ya trop de moyens trop d'argent
dans l'hôpital français je vous suggère
non pas de me le dire à moi c'est facile
mais d'aller dans un hôpital salpêtrière
et de le dire ou soignants qui l'ont
trop beau rien je pense que vous serez
très très bien pas de calais nature et
nous je suis animé français quand vous
leur parler en privé les dix tous le
contraire de ce que vous dites que les
35 heures sont un groupe emmené à
l'hôpital et qu'ils sont sur un plateau
ils disent le contraire mais je peux
aller suffisamment médecin vous aussi
vous diront tous que c'est un des gros
problèmes de l'hôpital et que et les
médecins qui connaissent les chiffres du
budget savent que le problème problème
du budget français ludopital français ça
n'est pas de qui son financement
je dis ça je dis pas qu'il est sûr
financées je dis que c'est pas son
premier problème par rapport
on va on va le la question de l'hôpital
et 35 heures est une question
intéressante mais c'est une question
annexe par rapport à ce qu'on disait
parce que par rapport à ce qu'on aborde
qui était concerne plus l'économie
française dans son ensemble
jorge j'ai une toute dernière question à
vous poser c'est quand même l'objection
qui est qui est fait par sylvie nicolas
et et christophe sur justement cette
inflation administratif qui vient tuer à
chaque fois lalala flics et à tignes au
nez la créativité beaucoup sans beaucoup
s'en plaignent
c'est quelque chose que vous
auxquels vous êtes sensibles de quoi on
parle
moi je peut vous amener des palanquées
de policiers de pompiers de militaires
d'infirmiers de professeurs qui sont en
sous-effectif donc s'il ya une inflation
siliana fondation administrative et il y
en a sûrement une ça doit pas être parmi
les fonctionnaires les plus utiles à la
nation
l'axé poitiers là c'est peut être cela
le problème est dans l'habitat la
question j'en arrive à charge
georges dor on va pas tourner autour du
pot s'il nous reste en plus peu de temps
la question elle n'est pas sûre elle ne
porte pas sur les effectifs là la
question elle porte ce qu'est ce que
l'objection porté sur justement les la
voracité administrative est ce que il
n'ya pas quelque chose qui mériterait
d'être simplifiée pour pour le bien de
tous y compris pour la fonction publique
dans les hôpitaux certains se plaignent
justement de de l'inflation de normes
qu'ils subissent mais bien évidemment il
y à des réformes à faire il ya des
simplifications a fermé jusqu'à
maintenant c'est réforme consiste à
enlever des moyens à ce qui concrètement
font que nous puissions vivre dans notre
république et j'ai cité quelques
professions qui malgré elle une toute
une série de réformes ne s'y retrouvent
pas ni dans les salaires ni dans les
moyens ils et les infirmiers se
plaignent et des raisons allez voir des
commissariats ils ont des ordinateurs
qui date des années 90 ils sont dans des
délais les murs tombent sur son décrépis
il doit bien y avoir un problème donc je
suis sûr que vu les moyens qui sont mis
on doit pouvoir réorganiser afin ce que
ça aille réellement au service des
citoyens français et d'aller tous
d'accord
on verra ça non n'attendirent tous les
cas mais oui georges le régalien les
libéraux l'acceptent
donc c'est un c'était la contribution
merci nathan vous avez fait pas mal de
vous avez contribué pas mal pendant
cette émission
et alors christophe 60,18 vous pose une
question georges en vous demandant si
vous ne payez pas assez d'impôts si je
vais énormément d'impôts et je ne
défiscalisent absolument rien du tout
c'est un point d'honneur et je me tiens
je refuse toutes les sous jacents qui
était posée par christophe c est ce que
vous en avez pas marre de payer trop
d'impôts non je suis content de lui dans
un pays je ne suis pas aux états unis je
n'ai pas à vous soucier quand ma fille
va voir un bras cassé ou est ce que je
trouvais discipline dollars pour le
soigner et je suis pour droit qu'à des
politiques et sur ma sécurité et des
enseignants qui enseigne à mes enfants
et je suis prêt à payer le prix pour
cela merci de votre réponse
donc c'était là que la question peut-on
travailler davantage sans renoncer aux
35 heures
c'est la question que vous posez donc
sur twitter et les internautes eux
pensent que non on ne peut pas
travailler davantage sans renoncer aux
35 heures à 60% alors avant de se
quitter